Here's a sales tactic that I rarely see
used correctly. It's called sell by
repel. And what that means is you need
to tell the people trying to buy your
product why they shouldn't buy. You need
to repel them away. And what this
actually does is it creates more desire
for the right people to buy your
product. So let's say you're selling an
info product monthly subscription, okay?
You're selling like a newsletter or
something. You may say something along
the lines of "If you can't afford $5 a
day for this subscription, then it's not
right for you." You're pulling them
away. Or if you're a lazy business owner
who doesn't want to work and put my
stuff into practice, don't buy this. You
may say something like, "If you're
looking for quick hacks instead of pure
fundamentals, then don't buy my
product." What you need to do is you
need to steer away the wrong people
openly, and it will make the right
people more attracted to your product
and keep bad people away from buying
your stuff. Sell by repel.